[Music]
let's go out to philadelphia i was born
and raised on the playground where i
spent most of my days and talked to lynn
what's up lin
hello dr john how are you thank you for
taking my call oh i'm hanging in there
hanging in there awesome hey you haven't
let go let go yet so that's fantastic
what's up how can i help okay
so um my brother hey hold on hold on
yeah
i'm trying to get better on this show
about um what's coming
and your side tells me i'm just guessing
come stone guessing here
that you know what i'm gonna answer
whenever you ask whatever it is you're
gonna ask
um no
no i don't all right i'm not there yet
okay i thought i was getting better at
this job i'm clearly not it's awesome
okay so go ahead and work through that
and then not call because i would have
figured oh that's what he's going to say
so i don't need to call okay awesome
okay let's do this all right so your
brother
my brother he is a long-term alcoholic
with anger issues and he's been that way
for
30 years at least
so my family myself and my daughters
we're not close to him for obvious
reasons but
were
close or social with his wife and their
kids
but we never discussed my brother
um
there's
there was a recent event with him that
kind of has blown up
into the family
with with the kids who are in their 20s
okay uh yeah how old is this guy
uh 61. okay all right
but my sister-in-law doesn't want anyone
to know what's going on inside their
house what happened
well just i mean
again years of just emotional abuse he
well he said something happened you know
did something happen so what happened he
was drunk he fell injured himself was
hospitalized
my niece was trying they were trying to
use this as an opportunity to
not have him come home but go into rehab
or go to the va
my one of my other sisters
he was reaching out to her not giving
her the full story
and dragged her into it and she ended up
somehow
enabling him to go back into the home
so
now my
nieces and nephews are furious at my
sister
because it kind of screwed up their
plans
you know so everyone's like
it's all awkward and but again with my
sister-in-law not wanting anyone to know
pretending nothing's going on
with the holidays coming up when i'm not
sure
you know do we just all go back to
pretending
everything's fine
um meanwhile you know i heard you
describe it in a protocol how the kids
are living in this hurricane or tornado
and that's what i feel like for their
for those kids yeah um they still live
at home
yeah they're all in their young 20s just
in college or finishing up college
so they've they've
they've lived this forever
yes exactly and nobody
man
nobody's helping them nobody came to
their to their rescue
nobody rescued these kids
and i'm heartbroken for
i am too um and i mean i always knew it
he was not pleasant but i figured it
wasn't
i didn't know until now that it was as
bad
as but you knew in the uh
you knew i mean you knew
right
and there's there's some guilt over
should i have stepped in should i have
said something and all that i think it's
important to own that guilt okay
okay and here's what this your family
system needs
in a desperate way
is for somebody to start telling the
truth
because your brother became a secret
he became
a shameful shadow in your family system
and
but how can we do that when his wife
doesn't it's your brother
i mean frankly i feel like writing him
up i mean i'm on her
i'm more worried about her and and the
kids
and that's how we all kind of feel
because as i'm hearing as i'm learning
more information from my niece and my
kids talking
the things i experienced with him
growing up
is
being repeated you know
i know
okay here's what's happening
i don't say you should the time for
intervention was when these kids were
six
they're they're adults now they're
grown-ups
and they have to live in a world where i
had a
raging alcoholic as a dad a mom who
didn't protect us family system that
didn't protect us and now we're
grown-ups and now we're gonna have to
make grown-up choices
you've heard me talk about the bricks
and the backpack thing i was at an event
um a few weeks ago in florida and i've
never been asked this question
a parent got up and said
you know your presentations you know i
love it i i'm thinking about all the
bricks i got to deal with
but more importantly i realized that
i've put bricks in my kids backpack how
do i help them get theirs out
i've never been asked that question and
here's the the hard answer
you can't
that's their journey now
and
a parent's goal is to put as few bricks
in their kids backpack as humanly
possible because the world will put
plenty in them they're kids and they'll
make dumb decisions and they'll have
their own to deal with they'll be adults
and they'll have moments where they
don't make great choices or seasons
where they make great choices they have
to deal with their own
but once they're in there that is their
adventure to to to heal and get that out
a parent can't reach back in their
parent can make it easier they can say
i'm sorry they can say i screwed this up
they can help financially
but that's the kid's job
and these kids got it left
and so you as how old are you
55 yeah i mean
you can't get in the middle of somebody
else's family system it's over the
ship's sailed
yeah what you can do and i think you
feel real guilty and you see it and
you're trying to re-correct it
and
there's a
not with you i'm not going to point this
at you i'm saying your family system has
significant immaturity running through
it it's you're acting like kids
hey we can trick him into or we can okay
now we got an opportunity to
it's like y'all are building a fort out
in the woods and yeah we got this stick
and we found this board and we
this is somebody's life
you can't trick somebody into rehab
you've heard me say this you gotta go in
there and flip all the lights on turn
the music on and say this dance is over
and
looking at sweet sister-in-law i don't
care that's my brother and i love him
and i'm gonna look him in the eye and
say i love you enough to say i'm scared
i don't want you to die
and
if you want help i'll walk with you
and that's it
and i know y'all don't want to blow up
the holidays the holidays are blown up
well yeah yeah and we've made our piece
with them we're putting it on covered
no it's not it's not it it
there oh here's
here's you can only work forward
what's happened has happened
i think
it would be helpful for you to write
yourself a letter
and say the things to yourself here's
what i should have done and i didn't
here's what i wish i had done and i
didn't
here's how i experienced that guy when i
was a kid and i was scared of him
still i'm scared of him
and i'm trying to help him peripherally
but he's just a nuclear reactor and i'm
scared of him
and here's what mom and dad contributed
to that
and
here's where we are now
because everybody's trying to do
everything at once and it's just all
weird and childish and what about that i
mean
somebody's got to be an adult
and you can't go fix his 20 year old
kids
you can tell them you could take them
out for lunch and say i should have
stepped in as aunt lynn and i didn't and
i'm sorry
i know what y'all went through
and if you need anything from this point
forward i'm here for you
okay
i can do that
with with my sister-in-law
i mean
i guess i'm worried then if
bringing it out into the open then she
cuts off contact with me she's a
grown-up
well right
here's a question you got to ask
yourself
um
do
am i going to be okay at his funeral in
18 months
because he's doing the he's he's on what
i call a long tail suicide
yeah he's checked out he's not he's not
pulling a trigger today but he is doing
the best he can to drown himself slowly
and it will escalate he's 61 so that
ball will get is gonna start rolling
downhill real fast
and he'll end up with some sort of heart
disease or cancer or some sort of thing
that pops up or he'll slip and fall and
break a hit whatever's happening it's
going to start happening with with
increasing speed
yeah and so i want you to imagine
yourself at your funeral at his funeral
standing next to your sister-in-law and
going good thing we didn't say anything
i feel good about that good call
if that's the right choice for you rock
onto the break of dawn
i have i have made it my
life's mission to have no unspoken
conversations
and there are four or five throughout my
life that i can't do over again and it
kills me
but my family will know
if i think they're gonna kill themselves
they're gonna know they're gonna have to
go through me first
they're gonna at least have heard what i
have to say about it
and they're going to know that i love
them
and they're going to know that if they
need something i'll do the best i can to
help
and then if he wants to keep on drinking
and being angry and being full of rage
and whatever he can do that he's a 61
year old man
and if this 20 year old kids want to
keep living in that toxic sewage
they're 20 year old kids that i mean
they're in their young 20s they can do
what they want if they're going to take
his money for tuition and deal with the
abuse and the beatings and watch their
mother just get stepped on
that's their choice they're adults i
think it's a terrible choice
i tell them to keep shoves money i'm
gonna be on my own i'm gonna go get help
i'm gonna be live healthy i'm gonna stop
this
nonsense
but that's their choice
and i can't say that when i was in my
20s i would have made a different choice
i'm just old man now
but all you can't you can't trip
somebody and kind of nudge them into
rehab and you can't use this as an
excuse to do a thing so you can do
somebody's got to quit being immature
say this is what this is going to be
and everybody lynn you included have to
start living for today and tomorrow and
not trying to i don't know this is the
past in it
what are we going to do today i'm going
to solve this today if it's my brother
i'll tell my sister-in-law i love you
i'm not gonna i'm not content to sit on
the sidelines when my brother dies and
he drags his entire family down with him
i'm not so i'm gonna say what i'm gonna
say i'm his sister and i get to do that
and then after that then she gets to
make her grown-up decision if she wants
to take her ball and go home
well god bless her hope she doesn't hope
she says finally somebody reached out
it probably won't happen
just picture yourself at his funeral
what are you going to say to to wife
then
how hard will that conversation be